Hey wisecrack,
corporeal,
jared again,
since destiny two dropped.
We've been grinding over public events,
the crucible and strikes,
oddly enough,
while playing and amazing thing
happened.
There's an actual narrative to follow
this time.
Sure.
The original had all the gramar cards,
but seriously time for that.
This time we get a glimpse into the
motivation of the Games and Agnes,
and it's not simple.
We're binge delusions of grandeur or
monomaniacal madness.
Nope.
The main villain of destiny two is
driven by the same thing that people run
on now,
pride and and woken list wisecrack quick
take on destiny two and as usual
spoilers ahead.
First things first,
a quick recap.
Destiny two opens with dominance gall,
also known as Gary Today.
No one is main is scary,
or is it something with a j.
The military leader of the cabal and his
crew,
the Red Legion assaulting the tower,
the last real city on earth dominance
and his crew up steel,
the mystical light of the traveler,
a giant planet shape God and kidnap the
travelers speaker who is a prophet of
sorts,
you play as a guardian and are now
screwed because without the travelers
light,
you've become a mere mortal,
so you have to travel the galaxy to
restore the travelers light and defeat
dominance.
Destiny has always been filled with
Judeo Christian illusions and
undertones.
The guardians are corpses brought back
to life with the travelers light like
Christian Salvation and resurrection and
the game all but says the travelers,
a god that sacrifices itself for the
greater good of the universe.
All of the crucifixion.
It's sacrificed,
destroyed.
It's ancient enemy and brought light to
the ghosts.
The main character's,
the guardians of the travelers light may
as well be the guardians of God's
defined light,
Aka his heavenly choir of angels.
Get it.
Guardian angels.
This light business is a pretty big
theme in destiny.
The guardians are literally powered by
light,
and when you die in destiny two,
we see your light fades away and what's
the opposite of light?
Well,
darkness still not buying the biblical
connection.
Consider this passage.
Ben spake Jesus again unto them saying,
I am the light of the world.
Either follow with me shall not walk in
darkness,
but shall have the light of life.
The evil that the traveler fled in the
original destiny was the darkness.
When you dive in destiny,
you saw the darkness consumed you.
The loss of light is the central theme
in destiny.
Destiny two gets a little more specific
and borrows heavily from a 340 year old
epic poem by John Milton.
Paradise Lost Milton's poem traces the
fall of Man and follow Satan on his
journey to get revenge on God by
corrupting his newly created paradise
and its inhabitants,
Adam and eve.
Destiny two seems inspired by one of
Milton's central motifs,
the juxtaposition of light and dark.
Milton's angels are represented as light
because of the goodness and illumination
of God's grace.
Meanwhile,
the demons are described by a darkness
and their absence of light dominance.
Gall in a way plays the role of Satan
who's angel name was Lucifer or Latin
for light bearer and goal is pretty
fixated on sealing the travelers light
traveler,
speaker.
While the parallels between God and
Satan are intriguing,
they're pretty essential to
understanding who you're fighting.
According to the lead designer of
destiny to Luke Smith Gall is motivated
by a sort of inferiority complex.
Gall was an orphan space turtle raised
to believe that the traveler messed up
when he chose humanity.
Gol was taught to believe that he is the
greatest thing in the universe since
Nutella.
He's here because he believes the
traveler and choosing us made the wrong
choice and destiny to gall intends to
show the traveler the error of its ways.
It shouldn't be surprising that this is
also Satan's motivation and paradise
lost.
Lucifer is pissed that he was skipped
over for that big promotion.
God gave the number two slot to his son,
and so he plots to burn down heaven and
tempt man to turn away from God.
Gulpie comparison is pissed.
The traveler chose the guardians so he
kicks them out of the tower and tries to
bend the traveler to his will,
the center of your God.
One thing that seems odd about goals,
motivation is the console galls,
adoptive father keeps telling him to
stop messing around with the speaker and
just to take the light what is right and
take this eventually all kills the
console and the speaker and takes the
light.
If he took the light anyway,
why the hell did he kill the console?
Why did he wait so long?
The answer is complicated,
but to simplify,
Gol was holding out for recognition is
seeking affection and love from a God,
but in a messed up way.
Recognition has a long philosophical
tradition,
but we're going to talk about what it
means for our old friend,
advil helm,
Hagle for Hagle.
People desire a self,
a sort of consciousness or what some
people call subjectivity,
and there are all sorts of steps that
people take to achieve subjectivity.
Recognition takes place primarily
through vision and in order for
recognition to occur,
both subjects need to feel like one
another are worthy of recognition.
Most people aren't reassured by a thumbs
up from Charles Manson because it
doesn't exactly scream you're doing the
right thing,
but a thumbs up from a role model or a
God,
well that gives you all the warm and
fuzzies.
Gall is searching for validation from
what he considers to be an equal because
well goal is basically a god given that
he is the emperor of the cabal.
Golf motivation for recognition comes
from the fact that he was a runt and an
orphan who was cast aside and abandoned
even giant space.
Turtles have low self esteem.
I guess dominance hopes that in
decimating the Guardian's he will show
the traveler that he's deserving of the
light and he'll be recognized as a true
subject worthy of protecting the light.
He's willing to do pretty much anything
like [inaudible].
I crucify the speaker in order to get
that sweet light or really got like
immortality.
He'll even blow up the sun.
Fourth Gall believes he is worthy
because all the sacrifice that he's gone
through because the guardians were just
picked willy nilly in destiny.
One goal doesn't believe the guardians
have sacrificed anything,
and in a way gall is right.
I mean the guardians were endowed with
immortality at random.
They don't have any fear of death.
They didn't pull themselves up by their
space,
boots or anything.
They just sort of got lucky.
We're makes your guardians worthy of
devotion.
Self sacrifice.
Speaker is the face of devotion
sacrifice,
so when the speaker tells him that the
traveler has never spoken to him and
that there's no chance in hell he will
ever get the light golf flips out,
kills the speaker and takes any way,
even though golf said word for word,
I will not take the light or a remote
force too,
so would be twisted faith.
It's here.
That goal becomes the villain of Destin.
Once he killed the console and the
speaker and takes the light.
He rejects the recognition model that
Governs Hegel's ethics and go straight
to thievery and university domination in
a full circle moment.
He replicates Satan's biggest sin,
the Hubris to believe that he could ever
be an equal to God.
So when goal is killed in the last fight
and resurrects as a giant marshmallow
God thing,
he has to ask if the traveler finally
recognizes him,
if he finally sees him,
but the traveler can't see him.
So there you have a tale of Hubris and
recognition.
Personally,
I love the strong narrative component of
destiny too,
but I also love just aimlessly walking
around killing stuff and picking up
loot.
I love the microtransactions a little
less,
but what do you guys think?
Should the game stick to the basics or
explore more of these themes in the
future?
Thanks for watching guys.
Piece.
Thanks for watching.
Wise crack.
If you're able to tear yourself away
from destiny two and are looking for
more smart content,
I recommend checking out our friends
over at screen prison.
They dive into the movies and TV shows.
You're already watching and explore
themes,
concept and technique you've might've
missed the first time around.
We've really enjoyed their game of
thrones house symbolism series where
they've been studying the origins and
histories of George Rr.
Martin is beloved characters and
analyzing some of the differences
between how the families are depicted in
the books and the show,
especially now the season seven is over.
You're going to need something to tide
you over until we get more,
so click here to head over to screen
prison or use the link in the
description and be sure to check out our
other videos and subscribe while you're
there.
And if you enjoyed this video,
keep on the lookout for our upcoming
episodes on the movie.
It's the enemy berzerk and much more.
Be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
so you don't miss what we've got coming
up next.
Catch you y'all.
Next time he's.